[Music]
making this mid-sized yacht starts with
a mold for the hall the team sprays the
gel coat paint onto the entire inner
surface of the mold this paint will
transfer to the hall during molding they
layer fiberglass strips around a PVC
foam core and create a series of
distribution channels for resin the crew
now drapes an enormous sheet of clear
plastic over the materials in the mold
and seals the edges with tape the crew
leaves a lot of slack in the plastic to
conform to the molds deep recesses a
vacuum hose suctions out the air beneath
the plastic the crew then connects
plastic tubing to the ports in the
distribution channels the resin
saturates the fiberglass strips that
surround the PVC foam core the vacuum
sucks the layers into a tight sandwich
and pulls out more air and excess resin
the resin cures and the fiberglass
layers Harden the next day the team
removes the plastic sheet from the
molded part
[Music]
a crane lifts the newly molded hull out
of the mold
the gel coat has adhered to it giving it
a glossy finish next they create the
yachts deck like the hall the crew makes
the deck mainly from fiberglass a worker
cuts out the strips in different sizes
after arranging some of the fiberglass
strips in the mold the crew builds up
the deck in certain areas using pieces
of balsa wood
a worker lays more fiberglass strips
encapsulating the balsa wood
they'll laminate the layers with resin
the way they did with the hall the crew
also makes the roof structure the same
way a boat builder applies putty to the
fiberglass to even out any
irregularities and after grinding the
hardened putty smooth they spread
polishing compound on all the yachts
body parts using a router the crew cuts
out holes for lights portholes and other
features and now the big moment after
six months of work let the good times
begin
[Music]